holding posters of geneva santos blaming
police violence for his death and
demanding justice in his name
a video showing policemen throwing
santos a mentally ill black man into the
trunk of their car and releasing a tear
gas canister sparked outrage across
brazil
black lives matter we cannot breathe
sang the crowd
[Music]
this sort of violence against blacks has
always been common but in the past there
were no cell phones
protesters are also demanding a thorough
investigation of the police raid in a
slum of rio de janeiro
the shootout earlier this week resulted
in the death of more than 20 people
we cannot wait around for the next mass
murder to happen next time it will be 30
40 60 dead we have to unite to defend
our lives
last year police killed more than 6 000
people in brazil
most victims are poor and black
more than half of brazil's population is
black brazilians will vote for president
in october and people here say they will
pick someone who will defend their cause
protesters say violence against blacks
and minorities has increased during
president bolsonaro's administration
he campaigned on security and gun rights
and he's running for reelection
the extreme right like president jaye
bolsonaro and rio's governor claudio
castro know that they have the support
of a significant number of brazilians
who applaud police killings in the slums
and poor neighborhoods the policemen
involved in the death of santos have
been suspended and the raid in rio
savella is being investigated monica
yanaki of al jazeera rio de janeiro